وسيارات وايران مقلقه للجميع وفي كل
المناطق الولايات المتحده اكبر قلقينا
طبعا لكن هل يمكن لوشنطن هزيمه المسيرات
الايرانيه رخيصه الثمن دون اهداف الصواريخ
المكلفه
وهنا عبر هذه المنظومه الدفاعيه
الالكترونيه
الحجم قابله للطي يستخدم النظام اشعه
المايكرويف كسلاح طاقه بدلا من الليزر
والذي كان يستغرق نحو خمس ثواني لتدمير
الهدف لكن اكون الحزم المغناطيسيه في هذا
النظام يمكن التحكم بها عبر تقنيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي فهو قادرا على اختيار هدف واحد
من بين عده اهداف او مهاجمته سربا من
المسيرات في منطقه باكملها في وقت واحد
اسقاط ما يصل الى سته و60 طائره في نفس
الوقت
هذه هي التقنيه تستطيع مواجهه المسيرات
الايرانيه ومنها شاهد التي يتم اطلاقها
على شكل اسراب يتم اعتراض عدد كبير منها
نعم لكن تلك التي تنجح في الوصول للهدف
تسبب دمار كبيرا ميزه اخرى في النظام
الجديد وهي رقائق ونتريد الغاليوم التي
يمكنها انتاج مستويات كبيره من الطاقه دون
ان ترتفع درجه حرارتها وذلك اعتمادا على
نوع المسياره التي يجب استهدافها وبالتالي
تحديد وتغيير التردد والنبات هذه ستقضي
على تقنيه كانت اساسيه بمسيرات شاهد 136
بالكاد تتركه اثرا على هوايات الرادار
وبالتالي يصعب اكتشافها الى ان تصبح على
ارتفاع في قطر